the most important thing is how you do
that without
putting you know a huge burden on the
user that all he wants is just to move
100 dollars between
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders
thank you for having me welcome
wonderful okay so
i messed up again and it's happening a
little bit more often than i'd like it
that i
i we begin talking and then i just
forget to record because i'm already
fascinated about what we're talking
about but i have the pleasure
of speaking now to somebody who was one
of the
people responsible for the architecture
of visas revenue streams
and just to put that in perspective
that's a company that deals with over a
billion
transactions a day a billion so
quite a significant role but besides
that office of the cto of silicon valley
bank
and lp at j ventures which i'm also a
part of so i'll repeat the question that
i had before your own
what does it take to lead the enterprise
architecture
for visas revenue streams yeah great
question michael and and
you can probably guess being a part of
visa
pretty massive company um in more than
you know countries all over the globe um
and
dealing with that mass dealing with that
volume brings in
uh huge huge challenges so some of them
are related to the ability to process
that amount of transaction in such a
short time span right every day
a billion plus transactions making sure
that you process it in 200 countries
sorry in over 200 countries you
mentioned which is over 200 countries in
over 200 countries
all the protocols and mind-blowing
mind-blowing um
and what's even more mind-blowing is
that you would need to apply
more than 10 000 rules on each and every
one of these
one billion transactions and make sure
that it's
taken into account in terms of how you
build it and how you service
it and how you price it and how you
aggregate aggregated et cetera et cetera
et cetera
so this this by itself is is you know
two pretty massive challenges
add that to the fact that everything
needs to be well secured
you know compliant everything has to be
audited to the scent
and and everything has to to really work
and and play
as in a concert uh with no disruptions
whatsoever
that really adds you know quite a lot to
the mix i have to say that i
recently developed a software that is
able to make
a thousand small calculations a you know
in a few seconds
and with microservices and all that sexy
stuff and i was so proud of myself
and now i just feel so small when you're
talking about 10 000 rules
over each transaction as a part of a
billion so you ha
you have my you have my appreciation
everything is relative in life
that's the first lesson from this talk
fantastic okay continue sorry
no no problem at all um so all these
challenges
and why you need to continue and develop
the infrastructure
in your software stack and the ability
to innovate and
to be open to innovation um
dealing of course with very very um some
of the
systems that are super legacy
modernizing that stack
fostering you know the the ability to
open up and and be able to serve
different organizations internal and
external that that was that was
uh quite a wild ride yeah no i'm sure so
so you know
give me give me a little bit of you know
the day-to-day of
is it stressful first is it stressful
and managing such a you know a
critical piece of the of the financial
puzzle
there's there's a lot of stress involved
yes
again revenue systems you have to deal
with money
and money is really really critical
so we got into situations when we were
at some
you know some occasions missing even a
few pennies here and there
even a few dollars here and there things
did not match
things did not settle and because of
visa reputation and the
commitment to be always 100
up and accurate there were some
stressful situations where we needed to
make sure that everything
is is well reconciled and and you know
we were able to send the settlement
files and and payments over or
essentially
charge the different clients the right
amount
so definitely some situations there in
addition to the ability to process that
volume
within a short time span how many people
are how many people were involved with
this
whole engineering feat you know there
were not
huge amounts of engineers involved
i i you know i don't want to to sound
like
like we had 10 000 people on the ground
essentially you know working to get this
machinery going on
um it was around 100 to 150.
wow well let's see it's across the board
incredibly impressive and i have to ask
because i'm what am i staring at
what where are you right now in the
world so this is actually don guerrero
pass
which is northern part northern ireland
of new zealand
and i actually have a habit of keeping
my virtual background in zoom
rotating across all the different hikes
i did across my
you know 40 plus years on on planet
earth incredible what
what's your favorite hike that's one of
the top five for sure
it's like asking you know somebody who's
your favorite your favorite child
yeah i like them all they're just
different is the
is there what is the lake actually green
when you're there
no it's just uh it's it's kind of uh you
know
looks like it's green but it's not it's
it's not actually okay great so very
talented
uh you know photographer definitely
definitely
so your own talk to me now a little bit
about about silicon valley bank
what what is that and what is your role
over there as part of the office of the
cto
sure and you know going from visa to
silicon
valley bank i needed to do some shifting
and silicon valley bank
is a commercial bank which the
population that it serves
is the innovation economy
in fact 65 percent of all the innovation
economy money
in the u.s is being processed through
tesla bank
um and we have you know a representation
over all the main innovation hubs so we
have a branch in israel
and in the big one in the uk and in
canada
and germany wherever there is innovation
spurring
you're going to find silicon valley
banks there what does that mean a bank
that is
that its main customer base is
innovation
what is that so we have we have a set of
unique products that is really tailored
and geared towards
startups private equity firms and when
we're saying startups
is everywhere from you know there is a
series b
c all the way up to established
companies that are already
you know in the nasdaq and are already
public companies
so we do have products that are tailored
towards that cohort or specialized
in in products that are tailored toward
that cohort and that that's really the
um secret sauce so to speak
right and and then what so so how does
that differ in the mindset
when you're creating when you're working
at an organization that is
tailored to innovation with all the
dynamics that it brings with it right
because i'm
because i guess different from you know
the average citizen
or the average company that has a bank
account you know startups
go up they go down they raise 10 million
they lose 12 million
so so how how does that mindset shift
exactly exactly right you just said it
so
you're talking about a cohort of
clients that is very different
because an early stage founder which has
you know
a team of 10 has very different needs
from
a corporate client that is a
you know a well-established company with
employees that runs on 100 million
dollars cycle
so they have different needs but they
are all entrepreneurs they
all have you know a need to to get
uh banking financial products from us so
that requires us to essentially have
different facets of products and
different lines of products that can
cater
towards these different sectors in
addition we're working with
entrepreneurs
and we all know what entrepreneurs are
are after right they need
things that work fast they need things
that work
slick they need things that are tailored
to their needs
um and they want to do that from their
mobile device
right so having a stack having products
that are tailored towards
what entrepreneurs are after and their
set of mind and of course they want
things that change i mean today
it's this tomorrow it's that they won't
they don't want to wait for 12 months
for somebody to come in and you know
come up with a product that's tailored
for ever-changing markets right and i
mean you're so you're
you're very strategically positioned
within this financial
uh tech industry is is what really
excites you about it why
why choose to go into banks you know
with your tech skill sets i mean you're
wanted in
every tech company in the world so so
why specifically
banking and finance so
i think because of that very close
interface with
entrepreneurs so silicon valley bank
sees itself not only as a bank
we're not that you know an atm you go in
and get
money from and that's it we're actually
building relationships so i have the
opportunity
as an architect to speak to many many
many companies
really and explain to them and work with
them and kind of give them an insight
on what does it take to work with
regulated financial institutes
and that that is very precious
information and something that
companies really really value so we we
do that we
we have the ability to connect between
different clients of ours because we
know that client a
might be well integrated with find b and
sometimes we even adopt
technologies that are coming in from our
clients which we always look at
favorably incredible so you get that
ability to really work within that
innovation economy that within the
innovation ecosystem
that was something that that was really
appealing to me and that's something i
for example visa was very different in
that sense right and i'm guessing it's
also a different number of employees
around the world and
the the whole the magnitude must be
different right because the visa is just
it's crazy juggernauts exactly so
silicon valley bank is a medium-sized
bank uh fairly small
you know smaller presence in in
california and in other areas in the
world but
i think the culture also because of the
need and the ability to speak with and
engage with our entrepreneurs
the culture within the bank is very open
very honest very authentic these are
things that i really do appreciate
but i have to really get to the bottom
of this because you're saying that
you're
you're a technology architect within
silicon valley bank
uh so it's an engineering leadership
role correct
so the interesting thing with what i'm
doing is i'm sitting
right in the junction between
engineering
business and products and that's that
that's my sweet spot
right so talk so that sweet spot i i'd
love to just learn a little bit more
about
what it means to to talk to the
entrepreneurs and to your customers
while having all these different hats on
absolutely and i think what it does and
what what requires you to do
is to really think like a product
manager
think like an engineer think like a
business person
when you are trying to roll out
technology changes and when you speak
with entrepreneurs so you bring in that
multiple angles to the conversation
so if you you think like a product
manager is
all features what makes more sense to
invest in
what what will will you know kind of
turn turn the needle or move the needle
when you think like an engineer is how
do you build your stack
in an open way your apis that you want
to expose
so partners like silicon valley bank can
work with you
easily where your your encryption of the
data that that you're going to save your
sensitive data
those type of of um you know uh
specific areas that that you can bring
to the table so you bring in a
a meal that that's made out of few
horses essentially not not just a
one-dimensional
angle yeah no definitely and then you're
but so you're not just drawn to
the entrepreneurs in silicon valley bank
but also
as a part of you know venture capital
and you're an lp
at the j ventures fund so where does
that interest come from
and and how do you balance that interest
with you know being inside of a big
corporate
great question so the fact that i've
been you know working with entrepreneurs
in the last four years
certainly helped me kind of getting
close to that ecosystem
right um i think that it really
triggered my interest
into the vc community and into the the
capital community
the capital funding community i also
feel very strong around
upon the the mission that j ventures has
with keeping that the gap or
closing the gap between israelis and
american jews
of course we definitely see you know
opportunities there and i'm excited
about that mission
so a combination of those two together
that that really was what was driving me
over towards
the eventual very happy so far a hundred
percent no no me too
but do you have that sort of like
irkness or those like you know
those goosebumps when you see the the
entrepreneurs and do you do you have
that sense of
well maybe one day i i want to you know
do
do go on on an adventure like that as
well or are you
happy with the intersection of you know
business and
executive technology within uh within a
large corporation while
investing can't lie michael i i always
have something in the back of my mind
that says how about that idea how about
this idea
so i do have a few things in the back of
my mind but that you know
the opportunity just didn't presented
itself yet and and
it's it's all about timing and the right
time and right uh
you know the right location so
my brother by the way is an entrepreneur
so he's kind of adding
a lot of fire or a lot of oil into that
fire as well and all the shabbat dinners
i'm sure
exactly so so it's it's somewhere there
um hasn't been materialized yet but life
is short you know
let's see let's see what we do in the
future
a hundred percent 100 no that's that's
really fantastic and i'd love to sort of
shift and
and understand a little bit better about
this about fintech and about
you know the financial world as it is i
know nothing about it except for the
fact that i
that i know how to swipe my credit card
and and hopefully check
pretty often to make sure that my
balance is above zero
i don't know much give me a little bit
of your insight into what's happening
you know in 2020 with
with finance and and how consumers are
interacting with their banks
and where are we headed from here sure
and digital is definitely
the big thing um digital
meaning that you don't want to call your
bank you don't want to send your bank an
email
you want to be able to interact with
your bank through digital means through
digital applications
you if you own a company if you want a
startup or or
a private equity company you want to
have apis
which are you know ways to interact with
your bank without
needing to even use a mobile app um you
just hook in your systems through apis
and you've got everything done
automatically
for some of your needs um so digital and
observation are really big
right now in the ecosystem um in the
commercial ecosystem
even more right so if you do have a
business if you need to
to do payments if you want to be able to
to shift money
in between accounts if you want to be
able to pay different deals
you want all that that to be very
automated very streamlined very simple
for you
you also want to have different payments
and different ways to pay
and depending on how you want to pay
sometimes you're willing to pay more to
get
things done quicker sometimes you have
the ability to wait with some of your
payments so you want to have the ability
to choose between different types of
payments you don't want just
two two wires one hundred percent of the
time
cards is another great example cards are
blowing up i mean
the cards industry is is just and visa
of course
was is the main benefit of the
beneficiary out of this
but the the cards industry and the
products on cards
are right exploding so loyalty
and the ability to do so many things
with virtual cards
and your vendors pay your employees with
virtual cards
that that's been a very hot topic as
well
so it's it really is a lot around
digital
from payments around automation um
that's what i would say are our three
main trends of what we see around
and how how how does trust play into all
of this
especially as things are transitioning
to paperless or they have transitioned
but you know in some parts of the world
you know i was just speaking i was
recently visiting mexico with a friend
and we were sitting with one of the top
startups there who are now you know
helping
digitalize the the banking system in
mexico and it turns out that most people
there don't have credit cards yet and
don't have
digital banking yet so how how do you
how does how much does trust play into
this whole transition that the world is
going through
um i think so so we're a commercial bank
so we don't work with individuals we
work with commercial entities
but i can look at trust from maybe a
different angle for you
when we talk about the identity yes and
the ability so think about it right
we're in a world where
a fake reality is very much becoming
almost the real reality in many many
different occasions and you hear about
use cases and occasions where
you know folks were were kind of uh
pretending to be person x and calling
person y and telling him to to just you
know wire a million dollars to that
specific address and they were sure it
was the ceo etc etc
so being able to uh
transact financially in a safe
way is huge right and for that there are
different technologies
um some of them are coming in in a
pretty big way
such as voice recognition
such as behavior biometrics behavior or
behavioral biometrics
in other ways that we are also thinking
of of how to do that transactional
journey
how to do that identification
multi-factor authentication yeah
all that good stuff to make sure that
you are you
when you try to transact with us is
critical
and the most important thing is how you
do that without
putting you know a huge burden on the
user that all he wants is just to
to move a hundred dollars between his
account exactly exactly your own uh
that's just fascinating
and we do have to end soon but i i'd
love to ask you the the last question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
wow three words all right so let me we
said we said two to four
so three is a good medium happy median
so how about we go with
um humble yes very important to me very
important
for me to to be in a place where people
are humble
um curious which really goes
hand in hand with humble being humble um
and really wanting to to learn and
understand more
and i think i am very focused so i'm i
got this maniacal focus that i
i actually jump on things and i make
sure that that things are
are you know done and
very very important to get distracted
so that that would be my three keywords
euron i think it's it's incredible
and uh i can't even imagine what it's
like to
to to even be a part of a team that let
alone lead it to that that manages this
infrastructure of
oh my god today it's a billion
transactions a day
i'm gonna have to go back to my drawing
board of a thousand calculations
uh yeah you can kill this baby up you
scale it up
thank you very much and i'll see you
around j ventures
thank you for having me take care have a
good one bye
you